[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
und nicht die lebkuchen
jetzt sprach ist ich wollte doch diese
nürnberger lebkuchen sorgen
die hat der hort gegessen
ich hab' ich habe die extra gekauft für
den dreh heute und ich weiß dass wir
gott dazu letzte woche gegessen
ich gucke mir ob ich hier noch eine habt
vielleicht einmal eine noch versteckt
nein das ist nur spekulation und
yogurette zeigt sich unser sie kennt
versteckter oben
sonst ja wobei er guckt sich das ja
nicht an nach im schnitt oder und hatte
gott die lebkuchen sind weg
ok ich fang noch mal an hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ja
heute packe ich morath kann es sein dass
du die nürnberger lebkuchen gegessen
hast du doch film träge braun der
limburger nürnberger liegt ich habe die
verträge braucht oder eben und eben
wollte ich dir am anfang zeigen und
denkst oh mein gott ich habe es dir
nicht mehr am strand ich habe sie wieder
zusammen ist okay ich kein science tun
also leute möchte auch modelle stimmt oh
nein ich kenne es einst und an
sichtbarkeit in nürnberger lebkuchen das
sind diese großen werden auch elisen
lebkuchen genannt ich hab die auch mal
40 jahren zubereitet aber ich hab mir
gesagt komm wir machen sie noch einmal
und damals habe ich sie als mini-version
gemacht und heute will ich so richtig
große wie sie aussehen könnt ihr hier
der faktor entnehmen kann ich nicht sich
nicht zeigen
da mein mann und meine vierjährige
tochter sie weiter schon gegessen haben
ok ich kann ihnen halt auch nicht böse
sein
die sind einfach zu süß ich jetzt ja ich
gerne gezeigt aber ist egal jeder weiß
doch wie lebt noch aussehen oder ok also
mir die zutaten was bei nürnberger
lippen und tatsächlich richtig ist dass
wirklich kein mail benutzt wird oder
maximal ich habe zehn prozent ist die
grenze denn die lebkuchen bestehen aus
müssen aus mandeln aus bisschen orange
zitronat und das war eine richtig
geniale kombination und das macht die
lebt buch unser super saftig aromatisch
und lecker
ich verwende dafür 680 gramm braun und
sogar 40 gramm honig hier habe ich die
lebkuchengewürz nämlich zimt muskatnuss
und in der prise salz etwas kardamon
gemahlene nelken und man den extrakt
jeweils 250 gramm mandeln und haselnüsse
jeweils 200 gramm zitronat und orangeat
ich nehme hier noch eine frische
ingwerwurzel und back opladen und wie
gesagt mache ich jetzt großer lebkuchen
und deswegen habe ich diesmal die
opladen mit 90 zentimetern durchmesser
denn ich finde so große lektion schön
was habe ich zeit
mit neuer sonderschichten diesen
lebkuchen der schrauber aber okay wir
machen halt 998 okay was gibt es zuerst
machen werde
das empfehle ich euch auch immer das
wenn ihr nüsse und mandeln benutzt dann
malt sie einfach selber denn so haben
sie wirklich das volle aroma noch hier
drinnen und sind einfach leckere altes
gekaufte gemeinden müsse das muss man
halt echt ganz ehrlich sagen was da oben
ich meine ich habe es jetzt schon
abgewogen aber ich könnte dir werde ich
auch hier abwägen und dann gehe ich
nämlich hier direkt auf sehen wenn er
jetzt hier drin wir wieder sagen türke
salalah grüße in die türkei ich muss
sagen wenn ich jetzt nicht für euch wird
die kamera backen würde hätte ich mir
das zwar auch nicht abgewogen sondern
einfach direkt hier drinnen kann man
sich nämlich ganz viel schelte sparen so
einfach kurz zerkleinern
den nüssen mandeln habe ich jetzt raus
genommen jetzt nach orangeat und
zitronat und da muss ich dazu sagen das
schmeckt man später nicht raus also man
schmeckt schon dieses fruchtige was ich
aber persönlich auch nicht mag ist wenn
man auch orangeat und zitronat weiß
ziemlich einfach furchtbar eklig aber
wenn jetzt ein kleiner und sich dann mit
den nüssen und mit dem mann wird
vermischt dann ist echt perfekt
vertraut mir ich gebe dir noch ein paar
nüsse mit rein damit sich das noch ein
bisschen besser zu erkennen lässt
[Musik]
jetzt gehe ich die eier in die große
schüssel dann den braunen zucker dazu
der schmeckt einfach aromatischer als
normalerweise zucker deswegen nehme ich
dir jetzt echt ganz gerne dann den honig
dazu
ich find es wird auch zuckerrübensirup
hoffen dass wenn ihr keinen honig hab
dann sollten sie so und das ist erst mal
schaue mich verrückt
damit sich der zucker einfach so ein
bisschen auflösen kann ihr könnt doch
die masse leicht erwärmen so auf 25 grad
könnt ihr auch gerne machen
dann löst sich der zucker auch ein
bisschen besser muss ich sagen
[Musik]
perfekt und jetzt kommen einfach nur
noch alle zutaten rein da kann man jetzt
auch echt nichts mehr falsch machen uns
am anfang des schaumig schlagen bewegt
wirklich auch nur dass ich da zucker
einfach schön löst und sich mit bayern
gut verbindet wechsel nun einmal hier
von schneebesen auch sonst höre jetzt
natürlich noch die ganzen gewürze dazu
zum einen ist ja auch vanille ein super
gewürz dann hier die trockenen gewürze
und die meisten brav muss hier habe ich
die reibe ich noch somit rein und den
ingwer habe ich auch noch rein also
jetzt nicht das ganze stück ihr könnt
auch getrockneten ingwer benutzen aber
ich nehme dir den frischen weil ich den
da hab ich sehe hier gerade also
irgendwas scheel ich sowieso eigentlich
nie
und wenn ich hier diese harten stellen
habe die entferne ich einfach mit einem
löffel also nicht mit einem messer
denn mir messer ist echt so dass man
immer zuviel wegnimmt und das muss man
nicht
also diese harten augen hier wegnehmen
[Musik]
und dann dazu haben so viel wie ihr
möchtet okay diese ein bisschen was geht
[Musik]
und jetzt alles nur noch kurz vermischen
ich nehme ich habe aus meinen fehlern
gelernt und ich nehme einen deckel so
sollte die masse dann aussehen also eine
relativ feste masse
ich habe übrigens auch gerade ein fehler
gemacht ich hatte die masse war einfach
zu flüssig und dann fiel mir auf dass
ist wahrscheinlich so große eier waren
und zwar tatsächlich elmayer
ich habe dann einfach mal die übrigen
zutaten dazu gegeben also bei allen
rezepten sollte immer darauf achten dass
ich in meinen mengenangaben immer mehr
benutzer also wenn euch mal aufgefallen
ist das bei euch auch was vielleicht zu
flüssig oder zu fest
achtet auf die eier größe weil das die
standardgröße unfalls ihr größere habt
ihr mich das einfach um rechnungen zeit
fragliche mit balladen wie gesagt 90
und ich nehme es funktioniere den großen
mach das jetzt macht damit ich guck mal
ob die masse ausreicht ob ich denke
schon
ja ich portion ihr erstmal ein paar
unterstreiche das noch bis platz aber
wie gesagt ihr könnt auch kleinere
machen aber ich will schon so
nachgemacht nur regional trifft sally
die großen lebkuchen
[Musik]
unternehmt ihr euch ein schälchen mit
wasser befeuchtet die finger so ein
bisschen und könnte dann die lebkuchen
masse schön glatt streichen so ein
bisschen formen
da gibt es auch so eine lebkuchen glocke
ich hab sie wirke aber ich denke ich mir
dann so nahe kommen
also man macht einmal im jahr vielleicht
lebkuchen
das kann man so ein bisschen rand lassen
denn das dehnt sich beim backen
aber so viel nicht nur schöne größer
[Musik]
guck mal wie schön gleichmäßig dies sind
es kommt einfach durch ein 1
portionierer wenn ihr könnt auch zwei
esslöffel nehmen
aber da habe dann nicht immer die exakt
gleiche größe und so hat man es wirklich
schön einfach portioniert
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen sie schon in den
backofen
den habe ich bereits vorgeheizt auf 150
grad und hitze und die brauchen so circa
20 minuten und in der zeit mache ich
schon mal die anderen fläche
[Musik]
da war ja die lebkuchen im backofen und
ich habe jetzt gedacht komm wir machen
noch eine vegane version denn irgendwie
das schon zur tradition geworden dass
ich meine rezepte die ich eben mache
auch in veganer weise und zubereitet und
im prinzip sind die zutaten alle gleich
bis auf die eier und die eier r setzt
sich durch aber das ist einfach
kichererbsen wasser ich habe ziemlich
erbsen in der dose und ist normalerweise
so der abfall der mann weg schüttet aber
da ist wirklich total protein reich und
ersetzt einfach ein eiweiß und das nehme
ich jetzt hier und alles andere nehmen
wir ganz standard also kommen jetzt kann
man alles hier rein wegen sein wer hilft
mir jetzt traut euch
die lebkuchen selber fertig zu machen ja
also sind es drauf machen
ich zeig dir gleich schon dann darfst du
samira fertig machen
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich einfach dass
kichererbsen wasser als ersatz und ich
mache sowieso nur die hälfte von der
gesamtmenge also brauche ich es einfach
150 gramm ohne aus dem gipfel machen uns
humus oder was leckeres ja da kann es
mal kurz gucken wie viel respekt zeigen
kannst du gucken wie viel
zuckerrübensirup aber ich nehme jetzt 20
denn honig muss ich natürlich auch
ersetzen
mein gott weil die sauerei gemacht dass
man nicht gleich mit
kannst du mir stopp sagen wenn du deine
zahl sie ist und zwar brauche ich 90
gramm
da vorne am display beim j
[Musik]
der krach es sieht einfach aus weyer
zuckermasse also gerade jetzt auch mit
dem zuckerrübensirup die farbe exakt
gleich und das machen wir jetzt kurz
fertig genau wie die anderen und nach
dem backen zeige ich euch direkt wie wir
die lebkuchen weiterverarbeiten
ich schaue man kann sehr naturell lassen
auch grad bei den in der packung ist ja
auch so es gibt die natur es gibt schoko
und es gibt die mit zucker und bei uns
bleiben immer die naturell übrig
deswegen werden wir sie mit schokolade
und zucker so machen sie mir vielleicht
kannst du dir hier gleich formen und ich
mache dann schon mal die schokolade
bereit ja
kuba hat dann so ein eis portionierer
voll abstreifen kann hier drauf und dann
also erst mal würde ich alle
portionieren und dann mit den fingern so
ein bisschen was mit feuchten fingern so
genau als außenrand lassen ja so und
dann hier drauf und passen sie neun
stück kennt so sein dass sie eine andere
backzeit haben aber doch immer und zwar
nicht so flach drücken nur sondern aus
der mitte opel haben sind bauch und am
rand leicht runter gehen niemand das
schaffst du oder
[Musik]
ja
die ersten lebkuchen sind jetzt schon
mal fertig hier sind komplett abgekühlt
die mache ich gleich mit schokolade die
warmen hier werde ich jetzt aber schon
mal mit puderzucker klausur bestreichen
dafür nehme ich jetzt hier puderzucker
und dann nimmt die entweder wasser oder
zitronensaft und ich mag es halt ganz
gerne wenn so eine leichte säure dabei
ist wer aber wie bei den originalen er
einfach nur puderzucker will im test
wasser vanille könnte noch dazu geben so
ein bisschen wandel ich jetzt nicht zu
dick nicht so dünn also nicht zu viel
nicht zu wenig zu tun sagt
[Musik]
wir machen wann die letzte drohen bus
oder bahn in eine zitrone
so ist gut schön dickflüssig und jetzt
hier noch warmen bestreichen dann zieht
das ganze ein bisschen besser ein und
auch keine zu dicke schicht auftragen
ich finde es da jetzt echt nicht zu viel
sein und ist übrigens je nach backofen
kann sein dass er ein paar minuten mehr
oder weniger markt also achtet einfach
drauf dass sie diese farbe ungefähr
haben so ein schönes hellbraun ich habe
die jetzt endlich auch einmal
nachgestellt
aber holen sie jetzt raus und dann auch
direkt nach dem backen immer unternehmen
damit einfach die unterseite eben nicht
schwitzt das ist auch wichtig damit die
opladen schön knackig bleiben
ich habe dort die anderen muss ich sagen
ganz ohne folie gemacht weil ich ja auch
gesehen habe dass da nichts ausläuft
ich glaube die veganern mache ich mit
einem cent gus-os nugat der wird halt
nicht so fest das muss gleich oder du
kannst einfach genug zwischen zwei stück
und dann mach ich dir so einen lebkuchen
lukas burger
[Musik]
und jetzt werde ich die anderen die
bereits abgekühlt sind mit schokolade
überziehen
ich habe jetzt hier zar peter kurative
und auch hier einfach drauf achten die
kuvertüre zu temperieren
zwei drittel davon erwärmen nicht so
heiß ich mache es immer so dass sich das
wasser kochen lasse dann den herd
ausmache und dann mit so einem schmelz
schälchen draufgehen und dann geht es
auch gar nicht heißer als 50 grad
ungefähr
jetzt kommt hier noch etwas kokosöl dazu
und die restliche schokolade also das
dritte kann jetzt eingerührt werden und
dann kühlt die kuvertüre noch mal schön
runter
[Musik]
ok ich würde sagen wir nehmen mal heute
den dennis dazu zum verkosten
dennis wird keiner zu uns als auch im
lebkuchen gemacht und weil ich ja immer
an euch auch denke und an meine veganen
zuschauer auch in veganer version des
wegen problemen wenn man also so
nürnberger lebkuchen
ich wollte eigentlich so das original
dazu erhalten nicht aber praktische
original trifft zelle wieder nach
gemacht aber leider haben die zwei
weihnachtschor wollte morella alles
schon aufgegeben aber kommen die sehen
doch schon aus oder witzig gekauft
deswegen ich habe keine gekauften mehr
da
naja ich habe aber auch welche ohne
glasur muss ich auch sagen weil diese
noch nicht ganz fertig ein blech
ich probiere mal ohne die rasur 23
[Musik]
ich muss sagen meine lebkuchen schmecken
mir auch ohne dressur dadurch probe
trotzdem mein liebling ist bitter und
ich mache den vergleich mit profis die
vegan schmeckt vegan schmeckt 20
ich muss auch sagen ich habe jetzt auch
deswegen weil es auch ein veganer ohne
glasur noch was sie gesagt optischen 0
aber das haben wir so generell wenn die
kugeln hätten die mischung also schmeckt
schmeckt exakt gleich und muss auch
sagen der hauptbestandteil von diesem
lesen lebt grund sind die nüsse und die
kandierten früchte und es findet ja im
prinzip nur und bei der veganen hatte
ich einfach weiß und stadt habe ich
dieses diese erbsen wasser was ja auch
genau wie eingelenkt und fand aussage
genau so aus sogar mal eben dennis
möchtest du unserer community noch etwas
sagen und geradem überlegen was könnte
ich ihnen sagen ja stimmt hört euch in
dem podcast an der ist super spannend wo
gibt's denn überall fallen podcast
streaming-diensten podcast kostenlos
kostenlos und unverbindlich
reinschnuppern ersten folge haben wird
alles durch
es wird noch spannender und
suchtgefahren und bleibt dran hängen wir
erzählen nämlich so unsere geschichte
wie alles begann
manchmal bissig aktuelle themen manchmal
alte thema fallen uns einfach sachen die
ich sogar selbst schon längst vergessen
haben sie eigentlich ist die therapie
nur kostet sie für uns nix ist echt gut
wir reden echt gut miteinander moral
also nicht dennis und nicht so eine
muratow nicht passiert also wenn ich
dann irgendwann vielleicht man folge
damit ist dann auch dann
das war komisch und ich dass wir hier
vor allem wenn du mit murat das wäre
mein gott dann mehr sein so attraktiver
man ja sonst hätte ich nicht geheiratet
und lohnt sich
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]